hello everybody um thank you and uh for
coming to this uh presentation this
webcast and
um hope that uh it will provide some
insight into an area of study that I've
been working on for quite a while now
just by way of introduction um my name
is Julian Lum I am a scien just at the
BC cancer agency uh in Victoria
BC um we're just north of Seattle on the
other side of the street um and part of
a larger
organization uh with the cancer agency
located in
Vancouver
um
so uh I wanted to um talk about uh an
area which combines
two very intense areas of research right
now one um metabolism of tumors and
secondly uh
immunotherapy and um the talk will
hopefully provide an intersection
between those two
areas so the other thing just
administratively before I forget is that
um this is a CMA CME uh accredited talk
there are some questions at the end
which you're encouraged to answer to um
get your
credits
um okay so first off I I just like to
thank uh and acknowledge the people who
are involved in this work
um former graduate student uh research
associate and other members past and
present um my colleagues uh Brad Nelson
uh who's uh the director here at the uh
daily Research Center Peter Watson who
um is an expert in uh
imunohistochemistry um and then whole
team at oare uh this is a research group
located in Vancouver um that has a very
um specific focus on understanding uh
ovarian cancer and a large list of uh
people who are involved in the
work um I don't have any declarations so
any conflicts of interest and uh thank
the funding agencies for uh supporting
this work this is just a picture of my
group here uh we're very fortunate to be
on the west coast and take advantage of
all the outdoor
activities okay so
um we now know that um the immune system
plays a very important role in uh cancer
and uh ovarian cancer is no exception
um this is a a slide that um depicts two
patients uh one of the left patient one
um has been stained well both sections
from these patients have been stained
with uh an antibody that recognizes cd8
positive uh
lymphocytes uh oh sorry CD3 positive L
lymphocytes in this particular case um
and as you can tell patient one you can
see there's uh quite a substantial
amount of tumor infiltration of CD3
positive cells within the tumor whereas
in patient 2 um there are very few of
these so um when you look at a whole
cohort of patients now um we've looked
at uh over 500 cases of high-grade
Cirrus aarian carcinoma um this is the
most prevalent
uh form of histotype of ovarian cancer
greater than 90% of patients uh present
with this type um and so if you do an
analysis of the survival over time just
asking the question uh how does the
presence or absence of CD3 positive lyes
associate with survival you can clearly
see that uh here in the solid line CD3
positive uh patients with high levels of
CD3 positive cells uh have much better
overall outcomes than patients here on
the dotted line with uh fewer or no um
CD3 positive T cells okay so this really
set up um the question for us because um
when we started to look more in depth at
um tissue sections from these patients
um this is a a one of the typical things
that that we might find so uh what you
see here is actually uh a single tissue
section that has been stained via
imminent
histochemistry um uh with different
markers um the images are then overlaid
and you get uh you can create a
pseudocolor image so while it looks um
very much like an IM florescent stain
it's actually uh an IM histochemistry
stain performed on uh archival material
so in red what we have is a pan a set of
keratin antibody that uh lights up in
red the tumor cells and then in
green pink uh we have different immune
subsets so for the purposes of this
slide it's not um critical to understand
what those subsets are uh what the
important take-home message here is that
what we often find is that um the tumors
while there are um lymphocytes present
in them um we find that there's actually
a disconnect there's a there's a
essentially a barrier between which the
immune cells and the tumor cells are are
demarcated so these immune cells that
are light lit up in either green uh or
pink uh you see that there's a problem
the cells are actually the immune cells
which are important actually recognizing
ding these tumors are physically in
isolation so there have been uh intense
research efforts of course to understand
um how not only can we enhance the
function of these immune cells but drive
them into uh the tumor so that they can
actively engage the tumor
so my laboratory has taken a slightly
different approach on this problem and
um we have been interested in uh
understanding what are the barriers that
prevent these immune cells from actually
engaging the tumor cells rather than uh
trying to determine immunological
therapies that enhance simply enhance
the function of those tea cells and I
think this is a very important question
because um
cancer imun therapies become much more
uh readily available and widespread
clinically um we need to understand what
the immune cells encounter and how do
they deal with the tumor tumor micro
environment so we've taken um the
approach of thinking about how does this
metabolic environment dictate um the
immune uh Invasion if you will of the
tumor cell into the tumor
cell um so we have been quite interested
in a a
cellular stress pathway um hypoxia in
particular and this is a a scenario
where cells are exposed to low
oxygen um in the context of a tumor cell
we know from a large number of studies
that as tumor cells begin to grow and
divide here shown in the
black uh black bar okay
um the nutrient
availability uh begins to become
exhausted so the metabolic stress levels
increase as denoted in this red bar at
the bottom okay so metabolic
stress and uh eventually what happens is
that these tumors begin to outstrip the
vasculature uh and the their demands uh
metabolic demands then uh necessitate uh
a secondary response which is the
formation of new blood vessels or uh
otherwise known as angiogenesis okay and
um and then uh the nutrient levels and
other factors are then restored to allow
this tumor cell to continue uh growing
and dividing and so I I will also like
to just point out in this slide a couple
of markers um that that we will use um
cd31 or cd34 is endo endothelial markers
of the
vasculature um um which while they um
Can demarcate these vessels um one
important consideration is that um these
markers don't necessarily tell you um
the functionality of those markers so
that's very important to keep in mind
okay so what is hypoxen and what does it
do and and why are we interested in this
in the metabolic
environment um hypoxia is a a cellular
adaptive response to low oxygen and in
in a in a normal situation where oxygen
is present a transcription Factor called
hth1 Alpha is uh
constitutively uh transcribed cried and
expressed and through the action of uh
an enzymatic reaction with these Prolo
hydroxy lases um what happens is is that
hip1 Alpha becomes
hydroxylated and is
recognized uh by
a e3 liase Ved shell to cause it to be
marked for ubiquit and in degradation
okay so while this uh protein is
constitutively transcribed
and translated it's also constitu
constitutively degraded under low
oxygen when cells become exposed to low
oxygen or hypoxia okay so this is uh
this here okay uh this degradation
pathway um is inhibited and what ends up
happening is that uh hipon Alpha begins
to
accumulate translocate into the nucleus
and bind to to uh what are known as hiff
response elements uh within Target genes
and the targets of hiff one are are uh
there are many of them ones that are
genes that are involved in
angiogenesis apotosis cell proliferation
and survival
autophagy glucose metabolism pH
regulation and other protic protolytic
Pathways and so I've just highlighted a
couple of Target genes in particular V
Jeff they part of the angiogenesis
pathway which will important for um uh
some upcoming slides and also um cell
survival Pathways autophagy uh which is
also going to um become important in in
a few few few more slides as well as um
ca9 which is uh also known as K Carbonic
and hydr nine and this gene or protein
acts to uh help regulate um pH levels
okay okay
so so one of the first um foray into
investigating uh you know the metabolic
aspects of ovarian cancer um is was for
us to ask whether or not t these tumors
actually um display features of hypoxia
or metabolic stress and uh so here are
two example slides of uh TMA where we
stained uh sections with
C9 and uh
lc3 uh and anybody against lc3 and I'll
I'll tell you a little bit more about
that in a moment so as you can tell we
see very nice C9 staining on the
membrane of uh the tumor
cells indicating that a hypoxic event um
had occurred um in addition that we were
able to observe some very unique
structures um called lc3a SLS or stonik
structures and so um if you look
carefully these dark arrows in the slide
demarcate uh these SLS structures which
are essentially very dense uh structures
standing positive for this marker um and
uh it had been reported earlier
that um these the presence of these
structures in other cancers uh
correlated with uh survival in fact we
we found similar uh um associations in
our cohort um what we what I show here
on the far right chart is an um
basically an association between the
presence of C9 or a a hypoxic event and
um U The increased L lc3a SLS score okay
so um it appears that these two features
hypoxia and autophagy uh are associated
in ovarian
cancer if you look at uh a cohort of
patients and this is a a cohort of
greater than uh 150 patients and we
simply ask the question whether the
presence or AB absence of this marker
lc3 asls correlates with survival we see
that if patients have uh or are positive
for lc3 asls in this solid line they
have uh poorer survival compared to
patients uh which have no lc3 asls in
the upper gray bar and that's true for
progression free survival disease
specific survival and overall survival
um in this clear cell ovarian cancer
cohort and so that makes sense because
one would expect that um cells that were
surviving through uh this autophagy
induced pathway uh those tumors would
have an advantage and therefore cause
patients to have a poor
survival okay
oops per me okay so um going back to
this slide um I just wanted to re
reiterate a couple of points and and
that is that
hypoxia um is a an important and uh
critical activator of the autophagy
pathway and this angiogenic
pathway and what I think that really
means is that the metabolic features of
a tumor as demonstrated by these Mar
recors of hypoxia could play an
important role in determining the
immunological fate of uh that particular
tumor and that that's why I've put put
another arrow here um to entertain this
idea that uh hypoxia can also have a
very important role on not only um the
immune response but patient
outcomes so um many of you might be
familiar with this literature already
this is a a review article that was um
taken uh that that was written a couple
of years ago summarizing some of the
very critical direct and indirect
effects of hypoxia on normal Immunity on
normal uh adaptive and innate immune
responses okay so um I won't go through
all of these um uh sections in detail
but um suffice to say that
um in the Adaptive immune arm
here um
hypoxia uh not only uh
impairs uh t- Cell Activation but it
actually can um cause uh changes in um
naive te- cell
differentiation um in particular it
drives the differentiation of th17 pH
type and uh also drives the uh
differentiation of fox P3 positive uh um
T regulatory cells or pardon me it it
causes the um increase degradation of a
fox P3 transcription Factor resulting in
um the reduction in these t-regulatory
cells and then there are also uh
numerous effects uh on the in innate
adaptive immunity which I um won't get
into today but um clearly play um these
cells clearly play important roles in in
the anti-tumor response and then as I
mentioned earlier um hypoxia also has a
very um important roles on uh the tum
tumor endothelial cells mediating the
neovascular Genesis um possibly also uh
promoting metastasis of tumors and
causing an overall shift in the
metabolism of cancer cells to rely more
heavily on glycolysis or or the
glycolytic
pathway okay
um so the question really for for for me
right now um is how does uh this tumor
micro environment influence t- cell
immunity um as tea cells uh become
activated they see their
antigens and they differentiate into
affector cells the the problem now is
that they need to Traverse into uh in
the case of a tumor they need to tra
Traverse into a very hostile tumor micro
environment one that has a lot of these
stressed response Pathways induced by
low oxygen nutrient deprivation
Etc um and so uh this is the point where
you know we really want to understand
what this environment does to the tea
cells and conversely one can think of
this more um in a normal physiological
response to for example infection or
inflammation which is also a very
important um uh sort of area to
understand how uh those environments
also impact um t- cell immunity but I am
going to focus primarily on this right
side which is the the tumor micro
environment so for the the non
immunologists um in the field uh and
listening today I just want to just make
sure I bring people briefly up to speed
um we focus primarily on CD positive
tector cells primarily because they're
the cells that are involved in uh
providing anti-tumor immunity but um
there are other arms of the immune
system that are also important um so the
general response is that an antigen
presenting cell um takes up an antigen
and presents it on its surface and
displays it in the context of MHC
molecules either to CD positive T cells
or CD4 positive te-
cells um these t- cells then uh go on to
become activated
okay and they begin to express um
important effector cyto kindes and so a
couple of the ones I've highlighted
which are relevant for this talk are
interfering gamma ti1 and granzyme B and
those cells that Express these factors
then go on to directly engage tumor
cells and cause their Lis and death okay
on the other side of of uh this Paradigm
is the activation of cv4 positive helper
T cells um and much in the same way once
these cells become activated they too
release various cyto kindes that as its
name implies help in
mediating uh the B cell differentiation
the plasma cells and those plasma cells
then go on to produce antibodies that um
neutralize tumor cells although
um this is not necessarily A predominant
uh way that that um CD4 positive t-
cells uh can affect anti-un responses
another important aspect is that C4
positive te cells can differentiate into
um T regulatory cells Fox P3 positive T
regulatory cells and these cells by
their nature and by their intrinsic name
uh function to suppress the activities
of both of these affector cells
okay
okay so uh we went back to our large
cohort uh of uh tissues from our varying
cancer patients um and began to ask um
uh What uh markers could we use to help
us uh determine the the metabolic
environment so using
cd31 uh we found something very
interesting uh which at the time was
somewhat
unexpected and what we found is that
cd31
High um expressing um tissues from
patients uh had much better
outcomes here than patients that had uh
cd31 low expressing uh uh tumors okay
the reason this was counterintuitive is
that one would expect that if tumors
were c31 high or positive that would
imply that there was uh an adequate uh
vascular vasculature Network okay and
please remember that um as I mentioned
earlier um this marker um the caveat
with using it is that it doesn't tell
you about uh the functionality of those
vessels um but they tell you about the
presence of them so um you know that's
one important consideration in this
analysis but if they were functional and
if they were present one would expect
the tumors themselves would have an
advantage they would be able to have an
unlimited access to all the nutrients
that are brought to this the tumor
environment by the vasculature and
therefore they would probably have a
growth advantage and and in and that
would result in actually um poor
outcomes or poor
survival but in fact we found the
opposite okay and so what I'll get into
that
um in a little bit more with some of the
data I'll show you and um this analysis
just really shows you that there was a
very strong correlation between uh cd31
hide um and
bedf U uh H tumors
okay so we also then uh did an analysis
to look at um whether there was a
correlation between uh This what I call
vascular density score or cd31 vascular
density and the presence or absence of
uh different tumor infiltrating
lymphocytes uh so this analysis where we
looked at here in panel a uh we found
that um there was a correlation between
a higher vascular density score in the
presence of uh CD positive T cells CD4
positive T cells in panel B and fox B3
positive um cells in panel C okay
there was also a very strong
correlation uh between the functional
markers of those affector cells so there
was a strong correlation with uh this
cd31 vascular density and the presence
of ti1 positive cells as well as Grine B
positive cells so not only the presence
but also the functional aspects of those
affector cyto kindes were correlated
with uh higher density scores
okay
okay so we then took a step back and we
um wanted to look in vro more carefully
at the effects of hypoxia on these
affector cells so um using murine uh um
te- cells uh what we did was we
activated those te- cells in
culture uh either in the presence here
of 21% oxygen or um 1% 1 and a half%
oxygen which is a a typical uh oxygen
tension used um to simulate hypoxia in
vitro right here uh and so what we can
find is that te- cells under hypox IA
here uh secrete much less interfering
gamma uh as well as tnf Alpha which is
not shown in this data
slide um but then we took those cells
that had been um cultured under these
conditions and co-cultured them with a
Target cell a Target cell that that
these cells are able to recognize and
actually cause
Lis and it's depicted in this panel on
uh the right hand side
uh cells that were subjected to
hypoxia had uh severe impairment in
their ability to actually Target and
kill their effector uh their target
cells compared to cells under under
normoxia this upper uh line
here okay
so what does this mean for patient
outcomes though
so we went back and we looked at the
same data
set and we compared um the or or we
looked at um the uh association
between U the the vasculature either
using cd31 in panel a or V jef in panel
D and we asked whether or not uh the
presence of uh these different uh t-
cell subsets or functional markers of
those t- cell subsets had any
relationship to overall patient
outcomes and what we found is that uh
regardless of the presence or absence of
those subsets or their
markers so here and
here patient survival was always better
when they correlated with with uh um
High vasculature essentially so uh c34
high or VF High here in the dark and in
the solid
lines okay um
so um what I want to point out is that
these earlier studies that we conducted
were um performed on essentially single
serial sections of tissues from these
patients and so uh while the markers can
be correlated with each other
statistically and we can infer that
these different phenomenon are occurring
together um definitive proof for that um
requires uh you know more detailed
calization studies okay um so we started
to um attack this
problem by the following way so what you
see here are three um uh images stained
with three different uh markers so
ca9 uh
cd8 and
cd34 and uh they're in different colors
uh
demarcated over here this is the same
tissue section stained three different
markers so when you merge these sections
together uh you can now begin to ask
very um specific questions on the
localization pattern okay so here's a
merged image of all three of those and
uh for Simplicity I didn't color code
this pseudo colorcoded it but rather
left it as the uh original
imunohistochemistry
stain
um so what we can take from this is that
a uh there are regions of hypoxia um
Here Pink donated in pink these areas
here okay I'll
just donated in pink okay here so here
are the hypoxia
regions this is
ca9
okay and um other regions that are
denoted by the vasculature so these
bluish vessel uh positive sting vessels
okay and then in brown um the presence
of t- cells so you can see um a
smattering of t- cells um but what we
initially found from this analysis is
that if you actually
drew
some lines of separation between areas
of positivity for vasculature here's one
here there were a much more te- cells
that were present in those areas
compared to other areas that were
hypoxic or or positive for hypoxic
markers here
okay so um
this really began to uh inform us that
infiltration of in this particular
example of CD positive key cells may be
actually restricted by whether or not
there was adequate um vascularization in
that particular region of the
tumor here's another example of that
okay so um again sort of this bluish
area where you have positive
uh vessels you see these nice brown
spots containing te- cells where all of
these other pink areas that you see
outside on the outside these pink areas
really they're
devoid of of P cells so this is one
example on the left and another example
on the
right
okay okay so this is again just a little
close-up image
um we've changed the coloring a bit here
these are the hypoxic regions the brown
ones which are C9
positive the te- cells are in blue
bluish greenish color here let me just
denote that so you can see them these
are the t- cells right and then these
are the blue areas that are positive for
the vasculature and again you see that
in the vast majority of cases there are
very few te- cells present in the in the
hypoxic or C positive
regions so we've now begin to
enumerate um with some painstaking uh uh
scoring but um this chart is is now an
interm analysis of that and basically
what we can find is that um in red this
is so each bar represents a different uh
tumor section in red uh We've
separated uh the tumors into areas that
are hypoxic and red or non hypoxic and
blue using those two markers and we've
asked the question whether ke cells are
are found in the red zones I.E hypoxic
zones or in the blue zones the
non-hypoxic zones and essentially you
can see there's a lot more red and
therefore a lot more te- cells these num
numbers up here donate the number of T
cells found in those red zones um that
are present in uh uh uh the nonhypoxic
regions sorry I think I might have
misspoke the red is the non-hypoxic
region and the blue is the hypoxic
region okay so um in summary um I think
what uh I'd like to uh leave you with
today is that um we feel that the what
we've been able to show is that the
hypoxic environment the the micro
environment of the of the tumor has a
very important role in dictating um the
immune the presence and the function of
the immune system and in turn um that
could have really important consequences
on the outcomes of patients okay and um
probably what we think is happening is
that this part of the immune suppression
is related to the metabolic environment
and as I said earlier on uh in the talk
I think that uh it's going to be very
important as we uh move into this era of
cancer
immunotherapies
vaccines uh uh te- cell-based therapies
those sorts of things um that we truly
understand uh what the te- cells are
going to be fac with what what are they
up against when they actually reach and
are exposed to the environment of this
tumor and really um how can we arm these
affector cells
appropriately um to overcome uh that
immune
suppression um so that's really the the
gist of uh not only um the research
interest in my lab but also this
particular talk um so I'm going to stop
here and uh I welcome you to uh ask some
questions I'm just clicking over on the
Q&A tab right now and I I don't have any
listed but um happy to to entertain
questions uh from the audience thank you
very much for your time I I hope uh the
talk was informative to
you
I'll just give a a couple of minutes in
case people are are typing some things
um and uh might be a little bit of lag
time for them to show up on the screen
um
okay it looks like there's a question
here
so the question uh from the audience is
could you uh explain the better outcome
when high numbers of fox P3 positive
cells are present along with cd31 high
expression okay so um that's a very good
question and I'll let me turn back so
that um we're all on the same page so um
here it is here so this figure uh
on uh the left hand side
a shows that um the presence of fox p3d
cells in the high vascular region
correlates with better
outcome and why is that possible if the
conventional and prevailing thought is
that fox P3 cells are suppressor
cells um so
um we don't have the uh specific answer
to that um but what I can say is that my
colleagues uh uh Dr Nelson and others um
are
now um really trying to dissect what fox
P3 cells actually um
Mark um there are at least five
different um uh
manuscripts or
Publications showing that the presence
of fox P3 cells are prognostic and that
patients who Express high levels
actually do better again why is that
well it turns out at least some of the
early data um not by my laboratory
suggests that fox P3 cells are very
hetrogeneous
okay so um there are subsets that are
actually cd8
positive and express aor cyto kind such
as interfering
gamma um whereas there are also
subsets that truly look like
conventional C4 positive Fox P3 positive
c25 positive suppressor
cells so um so while I can't fully
explain uh why this is the case um there
may be a role for other Fox P3 cells
that are not of the regulatory nature
that could be uh important in uh you
know the results that are shown here
okay so I hope I hope that answers your
question there's a second question here
um does it appear that tumor cells could
be influencing angiogenesis levels that
would best support their
existence
um
so um let me try to answer the question
if if I understand it correctly um yes
absolutely I think that that tumor
cells um as they become exposed to uh
these different uh metabolic stresses
whether it be hypoxia limitation or or
hypoxia or you know other nutrients that
are limited in the
environment um they begin to act
actually secrete um factors like FF that
recruit uh
angiogenic uh vessels from the
endothelium um so these cells the
endothelial cells Express the receptor
um that then signal to induce new
angiogenesis and the idea then is that
the tumor cells um are providing signals
that act that that act to uh continue to
support uh you know their metabolic
needs the high metabolic demands that
are required for their um existence if
you will as you
suggested um so I hope that also answers
your question
um
okay any uh any other follow-up
questions or new ones that I could help
uh
clarify okay um if there isn't any
anything more um even if you're in the
middle of a question you can send it and
I can oh yeah there is another question
coming so um I'll just read the comment
and the question we know that fox P3
transcription Factor occupies a promoter
promoters for genes involved in
regulatory T cell
function uh would you please explain
this aspect
more yeah um this is a good question as
well and um
I I actually um can't address it
probably to the fullest extent that
you're looking for because um I I don't
um I don't know that much about the the
the transcription factors that are
occupied by the fox P3 uh the the sites
basically
um so you know I'm just thinking that
one could imagine that um if Fox
P3 uh is uh present and it is occupying
these other promoters that um
potentially uh what could happen is it
could lead to uh feedback um if those
genes are involved in signals that um
for
example um cause Fox P3 cells to to
exert their um suppressive function so
one might imagine that there's a
feedback that would
um uh cause those cells to um become uh
ingrained I'm not sure if that's the
right word I'm I want to use um um to
maintain their stability I guess right
um but clearly I think what we're now
understanding as we dissect
these subsets of fox P3 cells is that we
don't know a um whether or not they're
they're they belong to one specific
subset and if so are those subsets the
predominant ones that are exerting their
functions on the affector
cells
um we don't know if they're antigen
specific meaning um I think there's some
literature now that's suggests that fox
B3 cells can be antigen specific but
whether they're antigen specific at in
their suppressor role or whether they
mediate antigen specific
responses uh in a different way bya an
affector phenotype um that too is really
unknown um but these are really good
questions um and you know it's going to
be really important um because you know
these te- cell therapies that we uh um
you know beginning to explore
clinically um will comprise and have uh
a mixture of different cell types um not
only how do those subtype cell cell
subtypes affect one another um but as I
tried to allude to in this talk uh how
do once those cells get to the the micro
environment of the tumor how do how how
are they going to be influenced
maybe when these Fox P3 cells get to the
tumor because of these metabolic uh
changes um they begin to express a whole
different battery of uh genes and uh
functions something that we simply
haven't um explored yet but worth
doing okay
um oh just give one last moment for
any uh remaining
questions uh do we do have a little bit
more time so um I'm happy to entertain
them
um
okay great well I want to thank everyone
again for joining in this particular
webcast for my
presentation um uh if you didn't have a
chance to ask some questions now I'm uh
happy to uh entertain them um by email
if you want um and so uh thank you all
again for coming and hope you enjoyed
the webcast
goodbye